mignon il s'appelle bob et grâce à lui
un meurtrier s'est fait arrêté il ya
zéro blague en 2015 martin durham est
retrouvé mort à son domicile criblé de
cinq balles dans le corps le perroquet
lui va bien rassuré sa femme glénat
était aussi présente lors de la taxe
locale elle s'en sort et elle est juste
blessé à l'oreille en revanche elle est
tellement choqués de ce qui vient de se
passer qu'elle ne se souvient de rien
pour la police c'est une intrusion qui a
mal tourné bode étaient présents dans la
pièce lors du meurtre de martin bonne
c'est un perroquet et donc il est
capable de reproduire tous les sons
qu'il a entendu cette nuit là lors de
l'attaqué ça devient intéressant parce
que les sons qui reproduit ressemble à
une dispute conjugale
tiens tiens et ce qui ouvre c'est que
ben hiba même jusqu'à reproduire le
sifflement des balles
finalité de l'histoire grâce à bob et
d'autres preuves concordantes évidemment
glénat se fait arrêter par la police
elle se fait interroger et elle traque
c'est bien elle qui a tiré sur son mari
bravo bottes et un sacré beau gosse et
maintenant vous voulez tous un perroquet